how's it going everyone my name is pin
five and welcome to friend I hope you
like that intro it's made by the red the
red panda 44 before I really really like
the whole all the submissions like all
of them were really awesome so I'm gonna
keep doing you guys can keep leaving
video responses with your own interests
and I'll try to keep I will keep using
them and
[Music]
I want to thank y'all for doing all the
favorites and likes and all that I know
a lot of you like I really have to click
this button actually to help out a lot
I've been on the front page of YouTube
my videos thanks to you guys a lot of
times now in Sweden that week so thank
you I'm not sure where I'm going with
this Friday's retweeted by a whole thing
I thought maybe I could
combine it with some real-life footage I
guess this is real-life footage - but
you know something you want me to do it
yes
what I want you to do is leave a comment
in a sec doing
leave a comment down below tell me some
weird I do maybe push-ups jump from
a trailer
oh here comes the beard stroking car
[Music]
actually hard come a little bit